- Taking a jet ski.
- Okay.
- From Chicago to New Orleans.
- A goat and two chickens
for a family in Africa
can completely
change their life.
It gives them milk
to drink, and butter,
and cheese, and they can
sell or eat the eggs.
It kind of creates
a renewable resource
and actually creates
a local economy.
- The best dressed jet
skier on the planet.
Have a good time kid.
- Let's recap.
It's day one of my trip.
I've done some mildly
condescending TV news, very fun.
I've auctioned off the rights
to christen my jet ski,
so we got the HMS
Rebecca O'Malley
and the HMS Kill Rock Stars.
And then,
0.05 miles
into the 1,000 mile trip
and we hit a lock, and
we're stuck for three hours.
(lock signal horn blares)
We are seriously fucked.
(invigorating rock music)
- Well, at this rate
we'll get to New Orleans
by 2 1/2 years, so.
- Surprise!
It is a bad idea to travel
industrial waterways
on a vehicle primarily
intended for divorced dads
to get drunk on, while still
seeming cool to their kids.
(laughter)
(signal horn blares)
- We're good.
- We're back on the road!
(inspiring indie music)
Let's get wet for goats!
Hello Chicago!
Have fun at work today!
Business casual, right
choice for Friday, guys!
I love the way you look Chicago!
I love the way you
guys have lunch!
Nobody has lunch like Chicago!
I'm Kurt Braunohler,
I'm jet skiing from
Chicago to New Orleans,
you're seeing the
beginning of my trip.
And we're sending 500 goats
and 1000 chickens to Africa.
Thank you so much
for your support.
Safety first!
Start point.
Ground zero.
Not in the 9/11 sense
but just in the sense
that I'm beginning here.
(plaintive Latin guitar)
Some say the mayor used
to live in that house
on top of this bridge
because he was a hermit
and he loved bridges.
Roustabout!
- My dude's hot dogging.
This is some classic
Braunohler right here.
Classic hot dogging.
- Now, the Chicago river
connects to the Illinois River.
And you've seen
the Chicago river.
It's pretty, they make it
clean for St. Patrick's Day,
once you get out
of Chicago, guys,
very quickly it becomes
an industrial wasteland.
There's a homeless
man living in a tent!
Like as soon as the
buildings fall away,
it just goes from fields, to
gravel pits, to junkyards,
to sand pits and back
to junkyards again.
I'm not gonna lie, shit got
real depressing, real fast.
And I'm the one who's
on the fun jet ski.
My crew is back on the boat,
and can totally tell,
they already hate me
for bringing them here
so I decided, I'm gonna rally
everybody, get them excited,
by giving Li'l Minnow
a ride on the jet ski.
Li'l Minnow, why don't
you ride with me?
- Okay.
- Let's do it together.
- Together forever.
- You ready to lose
your virginity?
- Yeah!
(heartfelt acoustic guitar)
- Here we are, the great sand
pits of southern Illinois.
- [Both] Sand! Sand! Sand!
- The water is warm.
- That's just the chemicals
burning your skin.
- Man, it's beautiful.
- It is beautiful.
That's when I told my stepdad,
I don't need to necessarily
go to a four year university,
I mean, maybe I'd ride
the rails for a while.
Maybe I take up commercial
fishing, I don't know.
(boat's horn blares)
- [Interviewer] What's your
gas situation right now?
- I'm just trying
not to kill it,
we've been running
it all day here, so.
Have no gas, we just died.
So we're in the
middle of the river.
- Then about five miles
outside of Chicago,
our chase boat runs out of gas.
(laughter)
And like, when a
car runs out of gas,
it just comes to a stop.
But when a boat runs out of gas,
it's just a fucking
free for all.
It just continues to go where
you don't want it to go.
Where's this magical gas station
that was supposed
to be a fucking mile
away when we started.
- They were closed.
- I mean I know I
didn't prepare for this,
but did no one else
prepare for this journey?
All right.
(jet ski engine roars distantly)
I'll be honest.
I end up yelling
at the marine crew,
like a real asshole guys.
It's not one of
my finer moments.
I'm mad at myself, I mean I'm
also mad at the marine crew.
Because fucking, you ran
out of gas motherfuckers!
Get your shit together!
But I'm the one who put us
all in this situation
to begin with
and now I'm watching
my whole plan
just crumble before my eyes
and it's only been five hours.
- Everybody might want
to put on a life-jacket.
- In case there's an accident.
We have no control, we
are floating out here,
and it's not a good
thing to be floating.
- This is uh, this might be it.
- As long as we don't see
a big barge coming at us,
we're good.
(barge horn blares)
- Sorry, Africa.
(tense desperado music)
- Help!
Help!
Heeeelp!
Heeelp!